late nights in the middle of june get
really hot and parts of the nation are
dealing with intense heat waves this
morning forcing many americans to crank
up their air conditions to stay cool
this comes as families deal with the
rising cost of electricity nationwide
the federal government says electricity
prices rose nearly 14 percent from last
june to june this year the largest
annual increase in 16 years consumer
reports tanya christian joins us right
now with her tips on how to help keep
those power bills down how you doing
good morning wow how are you thank you
for joining us now one of the biggest
things that can drive up those monthly
expenses is that ac bill yeah okay so
what can we do to help yeah that
accounts for nearly 50
wow you know the heating and the cooling
so what we like to say is why don't you
invest in a programmable thermostat
what's nice about these is you can
program it weekdays weekends if you're
someone who's home um on the weekends
but you're away during the week program
is so that it's not kicking in while
you're not home seven to ten degrees can
save you ten percent dialing it back
seven to ten degrees yeah what's the
temperature that you think you get the
most bang for your buck so anything over
72 in the winter and then 77 in the
summer
77 yes yes i put mine's on 78 but you're
not home
can get home you can turn it down okay
okay there we go
yes i i like my kitchen to be
comfortable yes um but you also say that
when you have your devices even if
you're not using them they're still
using energy so you're saying you should
unplug i don't think people really know
that no i don't i don't absolutely so
even when it's in idle mode thinking
about your phone charge or your laptop
charger your kitchen appliances they're
all taking up energy even though they're
not being used so you have to go around
the house unplugging everything and then
plugging it back in do you do that tonya
i actually do do that you do especially
in my guest room right people are not in
there most of the time so unplug the tv
tvs can account for 200 almost 200 a
year just keeping them plugged in at all
times yes now you said there's a device
you can use to show you how much energy
you're taking you're using yes so this
is kilowatt okay and what you do is you
plug your device in
like that okay there's a kilowatt meter
here and it tells you exactly how much
you're using even when it's turned off
it's in idle mode right now it might not
seem like a lot now but think about it
cumulatively if you have a toaster an
air fryer a toaster oven at all times
for the year you can save over four
hundred dollars
yes
okay so when you're sweating through
your shirt and you've got a big old pile
of laundry to do uh what can you do to
save money on that front run the cold
cycle a lot of people just use the hot
water because they think oh that's going
to get it cleaner we have done the study
it gets it just as clean and cold water
and then you don't have to use the
energy to heat up the washing machine my
grandmother told me hotter water makes
it cleaner you're saying grandma was
wrong
it was well-intentioned
well she's no longer here so that's okay
and you also say that we should buy
appliances that are energy efficient yes
consumer report they are so designated
aren't they yes on cr.org you can see
dishwashers washers if you are in the
market make sure you get one that is
green choice designated because over the
long run we're talking about from
creation to the grave we have studied
them they're more environmentally
friendly and more energy efficient okay
so what about led light bulbs is it
really worth going out there and making
the switch well it is if you have a
regular light bulb these led light bulbs
are super inexpensive
and over time let's say seven dollars a
year they you know you'll get that money
back however they last so much longer so
you won't have to be replacing them
let's talk about ceiling fans what's the
adjustment that you can make to uh help
the ceiling fans do their work yeah so
in the summer it's running
counterclockwise in the winter flip the
switch so that it's running clockwise
and that way that's going to bring the
warm air down and that cool air that's
rising it'll get filtered out i think
ceiling fans could go in and yeah i
didn't know directly yes hit the reverse
button there's a reversal
counterclockwise
where is the reverse i honestly got i
did not know that i thought that you
turned it on it just goes one way yeah
now if you have a newer ceiling fan it
probably has a remote and you really
just click the button other ones you go
to the top and you click it up at the
top tanya thank you so much we
appreciate you we'll be right back thank
you i love consumer reports yeah yeah
yeah